et maintenant comme tout va bien on va
faire une interview au cauchemar gal
elmaleh le pire des accidents conjugaux
vous faire surprendre par votre femme
avec votre maîtresse n'importe quoi
surprendre votre flamme avec votre
meilleure amie ou surprendre votre femme
et votre maîtresse ensemble bah c'est
sûr prendre ma femme avec mon meilleur
ami ouais c'est ça sert ips ben oui
c'est oui parce que j'en perds deux d'un
coup il en dira pas le nom du meilleur
ami de la femme de gad elmaleh on dira
juste ça un diplôme
cette soumission à réputé pour sa
discrétion exactement donc on donne pas
les normes un goal que des indices alors
le pire cadeau qu'on puisse vous faire
une perceuse sans fil un abonnement un
club de gym ou huit jours de vacances
avec vincent perrot un abonnement à un
club de gym parce que déjà avec un seul
abonnement je vous croise dans les
vestiaires ouais c'est vrai alors avec
deux je crains le pire
la pire situation au quotidien avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu une carte bleue
mais pas le code une fille super mais
pas de préservatif une fille super mais
pas le fond
votre cuir des illusions gad elmaleh se
serait d'apprendre qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans casimir que thierry la fronde avait
une chaussette danse en collant ou que
goldorak est doublé pour les cascades
que goldorak et doublé pour les cascades
parce que ça c'est dégueulasse vieux
dégueulasse
le pire ce serait d'apprendre que dieu
n'existe pas ou qu'il existe mais que ce
n'est pas le vôtre c'est que c'est que
c'est que dieu n'existe pas parce que je
pense pas que le dieu que quand quelle
je crois parce que je crois en dieu soit
que le mien mais c'est qu'il n'existe
pas passé avec le nombre de mecs qui se
sont fait sauter en l'air et qui ont tué
des gens pour dieu ouais c'est pas très
sympa s'il existe le pire c'est de
grandir salle de vivre seul ou de mourir
seul de mourir seul parce que je l' ai
déjà vécu et je dois dire que c'est
assez dur
ouais vraiment ouais parce que de
grandir seul je les fait vivre seul je
l' ai déjà vécu mourir seul plus jamais
au casino de paris